Officially, this suspension bridge
over the River Lee, in Cork,
in the south of Ireland,
is called "Daly's Bridge",
after a businessman who helped
fund it back in the 1920s.
But unofficially, it has a different name:
the Shakey Bridge.
Because it shakes.
I was going to film this
with my GoPro on a stick walking across,
but it's a really narrow bridge,
and I don't want to end up barging
into the people who are actually using it.
I can confirm from a
brief experiment, though...
Yep. It's bouncy!
- In the early 1700s, there was a ferry boat
that actually brought people from here
across to the other side.
But unfortunately between 1906 and
1908, the Dooley family actually retired,
retired themselves
from the ferry boat industry.
And it was through the philanthropy
of a man called James Daly, who gave
nearly £700 towards the construction
of a bridge project.
£700 in today's terms would be
around €50,000.
And to be honest,
you would not be able to build a bridge
in today's world for €50,000.
So the bridge was good value.
David Rowell and Company,
in London, Westminster,
actually had a bridge catalogue.
And the Corporation of Cork
bought a bridge off the catalogue,
and in early 1927 these huge,
giant wooden boxes
arrived on the banks of the River Lee.
And the bridge actually was constructed.
So in the first couple of months
the people of the area
discovered that the bridge actually shook
when they walked over it.
- Now, all suspension bridges,
actually, pretty much all bridges,
will move or shake
or sway a little
as the dynamic loads on them
from people and weather change.
And that's a good thing: because
if they don't move a little...
...they break.
The design of this bridge
meant the shake was more obvious.
It bounces up and down.
And it probably wasn't intentional(!)
But clearly it wasn't dangerous, as proven
by the fact that the bridge
stood for 90 years,
taking all the jumping around
and abuse
that local children, and adults,
could throw at it.
But nothing lasts forever.
In 2017, an inspection
looked at the corrosion and damage
that had accumulated
over the years on the bridge.
And, well, it'd been built to last
with good materials.
But we're near the ocean here,
and 90 years of salty air and shaking
meant that the metal had corroded,
and wires had broken and frayed.
The report said, in short:
the bridge had about three years
before it had to be closed,
and repairs were needed immediately.
So it was repaired.
Not rebuilt: the engineers reused
or matched materials as far as possible.
They took the deck of the bridge apart, fixed
it up off-site, and then put it back together,
taking care to keep the height
and positioning the same.
They replaced the suspension cables
with brand new ones,
and repaired the towers where they stood.
And they gave the bridge
a fresh coat of paint.
But here's the problem.
This bridge is on the local Record
of Protected Structures.
It must be maintained and repaired,
but it also can't be changed.
- There was public consultation, and
of course many people actually wrote in,
going "keep the shake, keep the shake,
keep the shake, keep the shake".
And in fairness to the engineers
who worked on the project,
I think they did achieve that.
People have had a lot of fun
walking across the bridge,
admiring the river, jumping on it.
Like, this has been ongoing for 90 years.
- Before the work started,
the engineers used accelerometers
to measure how the bridge responded
to someone jumping right in the middle.
And they found that the bridge bounces
up and down at about 2.3 cycles a second.
So as part of the design process,
they used computer modelling
to work out how the
new cables would behave.
And they made sure to keep the bridge's
total mass as close as possible
to how it was before.
Bridges shake and twist
in three dimensions, of course,
it's not just up-and-down.
But up-and-down is the direction
you feel the most
when you're standing up there!
And all the data showed that,
in all three dimensions, the repaired
the repaired Shakey Bridge was
moving more or less as it did before.
There was a slight change.
But arguably that just took it
closer to how it shook when it was
brand new, nearly a century earlier.
The bridge now goes up and down
at 2.2 cycles a second.
It would have been entirely possible,
with modern technology and materials,
to build an identical looking bridge
that was much more stable.
Normally, that's what engineers do:
they try to damp down vibrations.
But in this one case,
their job was to keep things the same.
Fixing the shake
would not have been preservation.
The goal here was to repair this bridge
so that it can survive,
and shake the residents of Cork
for another century to come.